l'incompréhension aussi est d'une autre
nature entre la jonction du maintien de
la tranquillité publique et celle de la
nécessité de l'ordre public
il ya un choix qui a été fait je le
rappelle à nouveau
il n'est pas fait par les policiers les
gendarmes ou les magistrats les
alternatives c'est pas eux qui ont fait
la loi
les circulaires pesnel elle s'applique
sur une législation et de ce point de
vue là gouvernements de droite comme
gouvernement de gauche ont été marqués
par une posture qui est de toutes les
dispositions possibles et imaginables
avant une sanction
or notre code pénal ces prisons pour
tous et pour tous comme ça n'est pas
possible on a établi toute une série de
dispositifs plus ou moins adaptés et qui
ont abouti essentiellement à ralentir et
à rallonger le processus du coup à
alourdir les peines car le paradoxe de
cette affaire c'est que jamais on a été
aussi lent mais jamais on a été aussi
sévère et du coup au lieu d'être dans un
dispositif de on a toujours le droit à
une deuxième chance et c'est raisonnable
de considérer ça parce que
criminologique mans parlant sur cent
prime aux auteurs 70 ne recommence
jamais donc même le rappel à la loi dont
on parle beaucoup ces temps ci est assez
efficace
par contre il y en a 30 % qu'on ne peut
pas identifier à la première infraction
mais qu'on identifie à la deuxième qui
eux pose un certain nombre de problèmes
et en fonction de la gravité de ces
infractions le système ne peut pas dire
deuxième chance troisième chance
quatrième chance cinquième champ sixième
chance 10e chance 20e chance 30e chante
parce que ça serait pas assez grave pas
assez important donc ça menacerait la
tranquillité publique yle injonctions
contradictoires et dans l'incapacité à
interroger la réalité de ce qu'est une
procession processus pénal une politique
pénale et on ne peut pas faire la
politique pénale sans les policiers et
chants les juges pour l'instant on l'a
fait sans eux et ensuite on leur demande
de se débrouiller avec
[Musique]